[Music]
remember the childlike Empress in The
Never Ending Story we do but why did she
just drop off the face of the Earth the
answer will surprise you any 80s kid
knows that the era was a time of soft
parental neglect and being low-key
traumatized by a variety of things like
your folks blowing smoke in your face
wandering the Mean Streets alone like
snake Pitkin and hoping your face
doesn't end up on a milk carton and of
course watching kids movies that were
spiked with some pretty dark sequences
who can forget renting the never- Ending
Story on VHS and being irreversibly
damaged by seeing a treyus horse ARX
drown in the bug
AR stupid horse you got to move and
you'll die rough stuff truly even for
the hardest of us between that scene
when little foot's mom dies in The Land
Before Time we all grew up with some
light
PTSD however The Never Ending Story is
pretty chill All Things Considered
thanks mostly to the fluffy look dragon
falor and the beautiful young Empress at
Tru is Tas of saving to be honest though
we had to look up the cast list to
remember what the girl's name was in the
film and she doesn't even have one she's
listed simply as childlike empress and
beyond that we had to look up the
actress's name too and how to pronounce
it strona stra straw straw snatch
straw hi I'm Tammy strak strak there it
is wait what it's not like this was her
Labyrinth and she went on to win an
oscal lator in life like Jennifer
Connelly but that's where things get
interesting and why we made this video
in the first place by the time stach
played the childlike Empress at the age
of 10 she'd experienced far more than
most of her peers she was born in Iran
to archaeologist parents but the family
moved to Israel when the Iranian
Revolution began in 1979
after that they lived in the UK for a
while before settling in California when
Stak was eight so her father could teach
her at the University of California
Berkeley it's exhausting to even think
about reminds me of when I had to switch
to the school on the other side of town
when I was a kid it's totally the same
thing anyway Straw's nomadic early life
didn't keep her from her passion musical
theater which she pursued throughout her
childhood discovered by a casting
director while rehearsing as piglet for
a production of Winnie the Pooh stac
auditioned and beat out Poltergeist star
Heather oo for the role of the childlike
Empress did they choose her for her
acting prowess or was it because they
just didn't want to bring the
Poltergeist curse to The Never Ending
Story set and opted to settle for the
safer option we'll never know come on
Tommy you know I'm just messing right of
course while Americans know the film The
Never Ending Story to be set somewhere
in North America it's a solidly German
movie movie it was directed by a German
it's adapted from an incredibly popular
fantasy novel by a German author and it
was shot at the German Studio because of
this much of the film's promotion
occurred throughout Germany bringing a
young Tammy straw neack to that country
straw didn't speak German but drawing
One Stop on the national talk show
circuit the hosts asked if she had
picked up any of the language why or she
hadn't she did have one Charming asaper
sleeve she explained to Vice in 2021 I
said I don't know any German but I know
that song 99 left balloons so being a
ham I sang it for them turns out stx's
joke paid off with a new opportunity
after seeing her performance a German
producer offered to have her record some
songs the family planned on returning to
the states in 3 days so the producer
wrote the songs that evening the
following day they recorded the tracks
and stac filmed a music video and did a
TV show appearance definitely a Rebecca
Black sort of situation except her
parents didn't have to pay someone
$4,000 for the opportunity everything
happened so quickly that the straw Knack
family didn't need to change their
flight plans Stak recorded a music video
for fairy queen and that was the
entirety of her childhood singing career
this was probably all for the best
though since her sudden stardom proved
to be a handful The Neverending Story
was a modest success at the global box
office and unfortunately for Stronach
the kind of attention thrown her way was
in intensively creepy and borderline
criminal Stak was only 11 when the film
came out in 1984 but that didn't stop a
plethora of men from acting like her age
was just a number several grown men
discovered the family's address and lied
outside to see the childlike Empress in
real life while that's creepy enough for
any child to contend with she also
received an engagement ring from a
German man stac told Vice I found
someone who was traveling to Germany and
sent it back because I didn't want to
take this person's money I felt so
guilty they're too good-hearted for this
work the Stog family opted to push
beyond the creepiness and put The Never
Ending Story in the past while Tammy
herself chose not to pursue further film
projects and focused on growing up
instead good job
losers really though things worked out
just fine for her strar went on to dance
professionally for the next 20 years
primarily in New York during that time
she met and eventually married actor
writer and producer Greg steinbruner
despite her best efforts to not hook up
with another artist as they say don't
what you eat not only did they start a
theater company together the paper Canoe
Company but they also welcomed a
daughter Maya into the world in 2011
finding a work life balance could be
difficult for any parent but stard set
out to incorporate motherhood into her
career telling Vice we live in a society
that often asks professional women to
pretend like they're not parents I think
it's so pain painful and so cruel I
wanted to say I am a mom and I'm a mom
who works and has a brain and can use
being a mom to make my work better Sammy
and Greg accomplished this by developing
content aimed at Children's Theater
education and film always seeming to
keep their daughter in mind stach
revealed her past as a childlike Empress
to Maya when she was three blowing the
young girl's mind with toys and
photographs she has also said that she
would support Maya if she wanted to try
her hander acting though her dad would
prefer she went into the fields of
medicine or law way less of a chance of
being proposed to by a random creepy
German guy
right okay so I lied a tiny bit when I
said she never pursued further film
projects after The Never Ending Story
Stak did have a miner role in a Czech TV
movie called Freddy asz lat of Alaska in
2008 but that was serious it until she
showed up as a fictional version of
herself in 2018s ultra low after that
she took her return to acting a step
further when the Uber popular Netflix
series stranger things thrust a never-
Ending Story back into the spotlight
with that iconic scene where Dustin's
long-distance girlfriend Susie
blackmails him into singing the theme
song over the radio with
her the sudden Resurgence of the film's
popularity in inspired strak and her
husband to tap into the Nostalgia craze
with their own 80s inspired fantasy film
man and witch the film not only Stars a
couple themselves but also a slew of
stars who made the 80s a memorable
decade for the fantasy genre Christopher
Lloyd Shan ason Jennifer Saunders Eddie
isard shereé agdash and Michael Emerson
to name a few stak's daughter Maya also
has a part her feature film debut beyond
that the film also includes puppets from
the Jim Henson Creature Shop adding to
the overall lowii 8s theme ultimately
Stak was only in the lever Ending Story
for like 10 minutes still she made a
huge impact on people so much so that
she regularly hits up conventions to
meet fans and discuss the role that made
her a star and that's not all like a
good number of people seem to be doing
these days she started her own Etsy shop
and surprisingly it offers hella cool
never- Ending Story merch including two
typ of autographed photos and a mug the
mug reads the more coffee you drink on
the front with a childlike Empress Below
on the back a picture of Bastion reading
sits below the more magnificent Fantasia
will become which refers to the
childlike empress's line and the more
wishes you
make the more magnificent Fantasia will
become she must be doing well with her
Shar because she has a five-star rating
and more than 700 sales when she's not
selling stuff on Etsy Stak spends much
of her time dancing and teaching yoga
she loves yoga and has taught it in New
York City for over 20 years in addition
to teaching classes locally she also
hosts classes via live stream in what
she calls NeverEnding yoga which
certainly proves that even in her slide
gigs she can't ever be too far away from
the work that made her
famous